>> Laura: JEFF BEZOS HAS LED
HIS COMPANY TO SUPPORT SOME
CONTROVERSIAL CHARITIES.
TWO OF THE CHARITIES LISTED BY
AMAZON OR BACKED BY A
CONTROVERSIAL BRITISH IMAM.
HIS TEACHERS INCLUDE THAT MEN
SHOULD NOT BE QUESTIONS FOR
BEATING THEIR WIVES.
PUNISHMENT FOR ADULTERY SHOULD
BE STONING.
WE HAVE THE AUTHOR AND FORMER
CHIEF ADVISOR OF NIGEL FARAGE.
>> HADDAD HAS BEEN ON THE SCENE
IN THE U.K., CALLING SOME JEWS
APES AND PIGS, SAYING THAT MEN
DON'T NEED TO EXPLAIN WHY THEY
BEAT THEIR WIVES.
WHAT AMAZON HAS DONE, THE
CHARITABLE THING, YOU CAN TOP UP
FOR CHARITY WHATEVER YOU
PURCHASE ON AMAZON.
THEY RELIED ON THE GOVERNMENT'S
CHARITY REGULATOR IN THE U.K. TO
PASS MUSTER FOR THESE THINGS.
BIG CORPORATE, BIG GOVERNMENT
CAN'T GET THINGS RIGHT.
>> Laura: HOW IS HADDAD ON THE
GOVERNMENT'S LIST?
>> THE BRITISH GOVERNMENT ISN'T
HOT ON TACKLING RADICAL ISLAM.
GIVEN WHAT HE SAID ABOUT FEMALE
GENITAL MODULATION            UI
GENITAL MODULATION            UA
GENITAL MODULATION            UN
WHY ARE YOU GIVING MONEY TO A
RADICAL ISLAMIC CLERIC?
IT'S EXTRAORDINARY AND
DISGUSTING.
>> Laura: AMAZON SAYS THAT THE
CHARITIES IN QUESTION, DUE TO
THE CONCERNS, WE WILL BE
CONDUCTING A FULL REVIEW.
WHAT ELSE IS ON THE LIST OF OKAY
CHARITIES?